a Wake County North Carolina District
Attorney reportedly plans to pursue
charging of 15-year-old suspect as an
adult in a shooting that shattered a
quiet Raleigh suburb police say the
teenager allegedly killed five people
including his 16 year old brother two
other people were hurt as Elise Preston
reports the killings have left the
community stunned
if he told me she was gone I said all
right yeah what do you say you told her
be safe
but Thursday was anything but safe for
Tracy Howard's wife Nicole Connors who
left their quiet Raleigh neighborhood to
celebrate her friend's 60th birthday
when Howard returned home he found them
both shot and bleeding his wife and
their dog lifeless on their front porch
I froze I didn't know what to do
you know
who tried to perform CPR or something
but
so I called 9-1-1
Connors is one of five victims killed
her friend Marcel Gardner was critically
injured in the Rampage I saw someone
walking down Osprey Cove right here with
a gun
what kind of clothing is he wearing he's
wearing camo he looks like he's like 13.
just after 5 PM police found two people
shot in the street and then discovered
more victims along a tree-lined walking
trail there are several families in our
community
waking up this morning without their
loved ones
officers eventually contained the
alleged 15-year-old gunman in a house
two miles away he was taken into custody
in critical condition from an apparent
self-inflicted gunshot wound his older
brother sixteen-year-old James Thompson
is among the dead along with 34-year-old
Mary Marshall off-duty Raleigh Police
Officer Gabriel Torres and Susan karnitz
a mother of three no child no
grandparent
no one should feel this fear in their
communities police have not named the
suspect and a motive is still not known
this is the nation's 25th mass murder
this year for CBS Saturday morning Elise
Preston Raleigh North Carolina